Mary's in Maine I'd like to know if you
have invested in precious metals no I
have not they're stupid my husband has
been talking about this for a month now
and it's something I'm not very familiar
with it is a highly volatile highly
speculative bad track record investment
gold and silver the / - primary precious
metals have a horrible long-term track
record when you look at the last 40 or
50 years of investing in them and you
will find people that have lost their
butts and when all the way up to almost
$2,000 an ounce it's all the way down to
almost a thousand dollars an ounce now
if the stock market had gone in half and
stayed down it would be front-page news
gold has basically about half of what it
was just a few my about 1214 months ago
and no one is reporting how many people
lost their shirts on gold so you do not
buy long term investing you do this long
term investing in precious metals I
don't buy precious metals at all because
I like my money I don't want to lose it
that's simple that simple thanks for
joining us this is the Dave Ramsey show